On the odd occasion that I do remember my
dreams,
quite often I have a dream where I'm back
in space.
I'm floating down one of the very long Mir
modules
I'll be going past at this nice, slow
rate.
Really sedate.
And then there's a window approaching,
and as I look out and see the earth,
with some blue sea and brilliant white clouds,
and the curvature of the earth,
my eyes are used to the bright lights inside
the space station
so I don't see the stars
it just looks black on top.
Then, floating the opposite direction, coming
to join me
is first Sergei, and then my other crewmates
who were up there.
We just stay around this window.
Together, we don't say anything in my dream,
we're just there. I can hear them breathing,
and I can feel their warmth because we're
really quite close to each other,
and we're all just looking out of the window.
Everybody talks about how beautiful the earth looks.
I always felt in a strange way at once disconnected
and connected
to the earth, because I really didn't feel
like I was part of it anymore.
I was looking back at the earth.
And yet, I knew that was my home.
That was where I wanted to return.
I absolutely wanted to go back.
Astronauts just look out and see the physical geography.
We talk about the countries that we can see,
and of course you're seeing them in different
orientations.
Then, after a day or two, you stop talking
about that,
and you start to talk about the things that
you're missing on earth.
It's all to do with the people you remember
back on earth.
Our families, our friends, and when we go
over countries
we don't think about the geography below us,
we think about the people that are there,
and hopefully future meetings with them.
How does that dream end?
Usually I gently wake up, and I'm always very
disappointed
because I wanted to be back in space!